(big band jazz music)
(speaking foreign language)
- [Narrator] José de la Rosa
is a third generation pachuco.
Defined by their bombastic way of dress,
pachuco is a term adopted
by the Mexican-Americans
and Mexican Nationals for a subculture
dating all the way to the 1930s.
(speaking foreign language)
- [Narrator] And that's how the
pachuco's way of dress was born.
This clothing was also a form
of protest for these men.
In the face of
discrimination by Americans,
the zoot suit was a way of showing
that they would not change who they were.
(speaking foreign language)
(big band jazz music)
- [Narrator] Although the pachuco scene
originated with the Chicanos
of Southern California,
the movement thrived in Mexico as well,
thanks in part to this man, Germán Valdés,
better known as Tin-Tan.
He was the Elvis of pachucos.
Not only did he help bring pachucos
into mainstream culture in Mexico,
he brought them to the
country's dance halls
where most pachucos can
be found to this day.
(Latin jazz music)
(speaking foreign language)
(gentle orchestral music)
(José laughing)
(soft electronic music)